good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1086
object class euclid
special containment procedures all
instances of scp-1086-1
are to be contained and quarantined
until death
while no method of treating or curing
scp-1086
has been determined it remains possible
to prevent its spread
so long as infected iterations are
contained as quickly as possible
due to the time-sensitive nature of
containment any mobile task force not
engaged in
immediate actions may be activated for
purposes of capture and transfer of
scp-1086-1
instances to central containment area at
site-38
in the event of a widespread outbreak of
scp-1086
any facility foundation or otherwise
with a biohazard containment chamber
rated at biosafety level 3 or higher
may be commandeered for containment
purposes
so long as containment protocols are
carried out in full
there should be at least one instance of
scp-1086-1 at any given time
this iteration is to be kept alive at
all costs
until identification of the next victim
is complete
use of any and all necessary medical
supplies are pre-authorized
for this purpose in the event of a
containment breach resulting in more
than one
instance of scp-1086-1 it is to be
considered preferable that multiple
infected individuals
be kept alive for fail-safe purposes but
the prevention of further spread of
scp-1086 is to take priority
over this however under no circumstances
are
iterations of scp-1086-1 to be
terminated
this will lead to further outbreak note
some concerns have been raised regarding
the extensive commitment of personnel
and material required
to the containment of a single
individual it should be remembered that
the priority here is speed
scp-1086-1 instances become contagious
within 6 hours of initial infection
giving 25 hours total of advanced
warning to stop a potential epidemic
additionally containment may require
seizing control of a specialized
biocontainment lab
in complete secrecy before administering
amnestics to dozens or hundreds of
witnesses
budgetary concerns are secondary dr
head researcher scp-1086
description scp-1086 is an
immunosuppressive disorder principally
brought on by infection with a
heretofore undiscovered species
of bacteria infected individuals are
designated
scp-1086-1 the disease has two primary
effects on the human body
first the disease causes the body to
reroute 90
percent of its leukocytes to a single
location
in the mediastinal lymph node forming a
translucent
gelatinous mass identified as scp-1086-2
during the formation of this mass white
blood cells are converted into a mass of
closely interconnected neurons
glial cells synapses and circulatory
tissue
the final mass will be composed
principally of these cells
and the bacteria responsible for
transmitting scp-1086
making scp-1086-2 especially dangerous
the bacteria responsible for scp-1086
has shown total immunity
to bacteriostatic antibiotic agents
and a near-total immunity to
bacteriocytic
antibiotic agents in those cases in
which bacteriocytic treatments are
effective
the bacteria's rapid rate of
reproduction effectively nullifies the
treatment's effect
second due to the sudden near tonal
suppression of the body's immune system
infected individuals will develop
multiple opportunistic infections
leading to the victim's rapid death the
bacterial species responsible for
scp-1086
is only found in infected humans and in
scp-1086-2
it has not been located in any other
environment or species
scp-1086-2 is produced by affected
individuals during the course of the
disease
and is one of the principal vectors for
transmission of scp-1086
previously thought to be the only
principal vector
a marked difference between scp-1086
contamination
and other immunosuppressive syndromes is
the pattern displayed by the
opportunistic infections that ultimately
result in the patient's deaths
while other immune suppressing disorders
result in a wide variety of different
infections
scp-1086-1 iterations consistently
contract infections
in a particular pattern detailed below
the course of scp-1086 is included
in addendum 1086-1
addendum 1086-1
scp-1086 infection pattern
stage 1 initial infection either through
contact with bacteria or through death
of prior instance of scp-1086-1
patient will rapidly lose immune system
protection and fall prey to any number
of dermatological diseases
the full list is included in document
1086-32
however regardless of the exact nature
of the infection
all stage 1 symptoms will be skin
related and all will result specifically
in severe pock marking and blistering
in geometric shapes across the patient's
body without skin grafts
scp-1086-1 iterations will die before
entering stage 2.
as per containment procedures this is to
be avoided at all costs
scp-1086-2 will begin to form in the
upper chest
of affected individuals integrate itself
into the nervous system and begin
sending messages to the brain this
process reverts the body's leukocytes to
a pluripotent form
and reassigns them as neuronal tissue
this process is very energy taxing
and will burn through affected
individuals stored fat deposits quickly
massive amounts of supplementary
nutrition must be supplied to scp-1086-1
to avoid death at this stage infected
individuals become contagious
6 hours after initial infection stage 2
beginning of neurological symptoms 18
hours after initial infection
scp-1086-1 iterations will become
intensely feverish and lose the ability
to form coherent sentences
during most of their waking hours
speaking mostly in rambling passages
with no discernible meanings
the words will be clearly spoken but the
sentences will be incomprehensible
in most instances the only consistency
in this stage is the insistence on the
part of the affected individuals that
they are
lost without any further explanation
most patients will likewise contract
conjunctivitis during this stage
though all other symptoms will be
neurological in nature
scp-1086-2 will begin sending
increasingly complex signals to the
brain
which affected individuals will perceive
as droning music
and mumbling voices it is believed that
the utterances from scp-1086-1 are
attempts to
process or describe these sounds the
subject's brain
and scp-1086-2 will battle for control
over infected subjects bodies
with the brain invariably losing stage 3
total takeover by scp-1086-2
48 hours after initial infection
cerebral tissue infected individuals
will begin to decay to an unusable
extent
giving scp-1086-2 increased control
over affected individuals bodies
particularly the speech
centers of the brain during this time
scp-1086-1
iterations will begin uttering a name
and a series of numbers
these numbers can be processed into
rough coordinates describing a location
somewhere on earth
these messages will be interspersed with
hysterical periods of unintelligible
babbling
believed to be attempts on the part of
scp-1086-2 to request assistance
individuals will repeat these phrases
for one hour
at which point scp-1086-1 will go into
convulsions
and expel scp-1086-2 orally
all personnel must wear biohazard level
4 blue suits
during stage 3. any violation will
result in quarantine
as a new iteration of scp-1086-1
as infection is almost certain without
total isolation from the contaminated
environment
infected individuals will enter a
comatose state
and die within six hours after expulsion
twelve hours after the death of one
scp-1086-1 iteration
the individual named during stage 3 will
spontaneously contract scp-1086
and become symptomatic all foundation
task forces within the range of the
designated location are to converge on
the area
locate the named individual and deliver
him in order
of preference depending on the amount of
time required to capture the individual
to site 38 any foundation location
equipped with biohazardous containment
facilities
or any civilian facility with equivalent
specifications
task forces involved in such operations
are authorized to use whatever means
necessary
to commandeer such facilities than call
for foundation reinforcements
containment of named specimens is
paramount
addendum 1086 to discovery and
concealment record
on july 8th 1994 over 200 small
gelatinous masses
fell onto the town of oakville
washington usa
these were found to be the initial
iterations of scp-1086-2
individuals were infected with scp-1086
foundation personnel surrounded and
quarantined the town
and were successful in capturing all
contaminated individuals
while the use of amnestic agents allowed
for the suppression of news of the event
the event reoccurred five more times
over the next
days mobile task force gamma 5 red
herring
was unable to completely prevent all
news of the phenomenon from escaping
but was successful in creating multiple
false leads and misdirecting the public
understanding of the event
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
banker zargaram
professor puffer the morrigan
retalias karim el ashmuy
[Music]
revenant brian sanchez
matthew gilmore eric corbeage
kauai fire keeper longinus
carcass death aqua king madding
james saba nj vojak
and oblong doucheboy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen thank you
you